in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to solve a system of linear
equations with three variables and three
equations using the substitution method
so you're probably familiar with the
elimination method but here we're going
to talk about the substitution method
another way of solving these systems so
go ahead and take a screenshot of this
if you want to attempt it on your own
and go ahead and see if you can solve it
but the first thing you want to do when
you're using the substitution method is
you want to solve for one of the
variables either the x the y or the z
and it doesn't matter you can solve for
this x this y this z or this x down here
or this z but usually what i do is i try
to solve for one of the variables that
has a coefficient
of one so like in this case if i wanted
to solve for this x right here you know
i could uh get it by itself on one side
of the equation and i wouldn't have to
divide like whereas here if i solve for
x here i'd have to divide by 3 i would
have some fractions it might be a little
bit more difficult you'll still get the
same answer in the end
but i think for this problem here what
i'll do is
i'm going to use this middle equation
i'm going to solve for this x right here
and so if i do that i get x equals
positive y
negative 2 z and negative 4. so
basically remember when you move uh from
one side of the equation the other the
sign changes so i just added y to get
that to the other side and i subtracted
2z to get that to the other side of the
equation
so now we know what x equals it's this y
minus 2 z minus 4. but what we're going
to do now is we're going to put that in
place of x this is the substitution part
okay in place of x
and the other two equations that we
haven't used yet so if i do that the top
equation would look like
y minus 2z
minus 4
plus y plus z equals 3.
and the other equation i'll put it over
here is going to be 3 times y minus 2z
minus 4
plus y minus z
equals 7.
so what i'm going to do now that we've
done those substitutions i'm just going
to simplify a little bit so i've got y
and y that's 2y i've got negative 2z and
1z that's negative 1z
this negative 4 i'm going to add 4 to
the other side of the equation to get
this equal to 7. so i just kind of
cleaned it up a little bit if that makes
sense so that's
one of our equations and then the other
one i'm going to distribute that 3 into
the parentheses just kind of condense
this down a little bit
oops that's going to be a negative 12.
and then now let's clean it up a little
bit further we've got 3y and 1y which is
4y
we've got negative 6c and negative 1z
which is negative 7z
and this negative 12 i'm going to add to
the other side which is going to give us
equal to 19.
so now at this point you can see we've
got
two equations that have two variables
and we want to get this down to one
equation with one variable so what we're
going to do is we're going to do that
substitution method again
okay but this time what i'm going to do
is i'm going to solve for
this z so i'm going to get the z by
itself so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to
add the z to the right
and i'm going to subtract the 7 to the
left so that's going to be 2y minus 7.
so that's what z is equal to so z e z
equals 2y minus 7 we can put that in
place of z and this other equation so
that's going to be 4y minus 7
times what z is which is 2y minus 7
equals 19. and if i simplify a little
bit here negative 14y
plus 49
okay and simplify a little bit further
we've got negative 10y subtract the 49
and if i divide both sides by negative
10 we get y is equal to
3.
so you can see what we did is we did the
substitution
method twice really once when we had the
three variable three equations and then
we solve for
one of the variables again we had the
two variables two equations but now that
we have y equals three we have to figure
out what the other variables are and
what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna go ahead and take this y
equals 3
put it in place of y here
so that will give us 6 minus 7 which is
negative 1. so we have z equals negative
1.
and now that we know
y and z
we can put those in over here to solve
for x so you can see this is going to be
3
minus
2 times negative 1 which is going to be
positive 2 minus 4 which comes out to 1.
so we have x equals 1
and if we write our final answer as a
triple x y z alphabetical order this is
going to be 1 3
negative 1
and you solve that system of equations
using the substitution method if you
want to see another example of how to
solve
using the substitution method i'll put a
video on the screen here that you can
check out and if you want to learn more
about algebra 2 concepts i do have an
algebra 2 video course for sale that you
can purchase
otherwise i will see you in the next
video